I used to love coming to music stores
like this where after an hour of
browsing I'd buy an album or two for
about 20 to 30 dollars then I got hooked
on iTunes where I could download songs
for dollar apiece now I spend 10 dollars
a month for over 20 million songs I can
stream on my phone or my computer
services like Spotify are do and Google
music I'll offer pretty much the same
thing on demand music where you can
listen to really any song you want at
any time they're not like Pandora which
is really just a streaming radio service
and now beats the company that makes
these very trendy headphones is entering
the on-demand streaming space with an
app you're going to want to try out but
beats does better than all the others is
help you find stuff you actually want to
listen to amongst those millions of
songs available on the iPhone Android
and Windows Phone the app does this by
getting pretty personal with you when
you first sign up you tap on these
floating circles to identify what sort
of genre of music you like one tap for a
like two taps for a love and a press and
hold for a hate the next step is telling
it what sorts of bands you like based on
those genres be honest lying about your
tastes does no one any good
don't judge me with that beats feels
like it knows me well enough to start
suggesting music on this just for you
tab they've already made some really
good recommendations but the best part
of the music discovery is as part of the
app called the sentence and I can
actually tell beats where I am what I'd
like to be doing who I'm with and what
kind of music I'd like to listen to so
let's try I'm at home feel like chilling
out with my family to indie and then I
can just hit play and I've got a new
playlist you can get even crazier with
it like I'm on the streets and feel like
making bad choices with zombies to music
from the 60s or the hell are all the
zombies when I like a song choice beats
is made it's a quick and easy step to
adding the artists entire album to your
library and even download it for offline
listening when you don't have cell
service but the big question is how did
it be stack up against the others in
this space especially Spotify which has
become the darling of the streaming
world in spite of its pretty clunky app
all the main competitors charge $9.99 a
month for on-demand streaming across all
devices with no ads however Spotify and
Rdio offer a free option with ads and
limited functionality Google music and
beats
don't offer any free option and remember
with all of these you don't actually own
the music
none of these on-demand music services
let you download them for keeps like
iTunes if you stopped paying for your
subscription the tracks go away Spotify
and Rdio also have better websites and
social integration than beats most offer
the same selection of music but there
are a few artists that can only be found
on some of these services for instance
Led Zeppelin fans will find a whole lot
of love on Spotify but none on Beats or
RDO or Google Music all access
sadly no Beatles available on any of the
services still I'm loving beats the
interface is more lively than the others
at least until Spotify releases its new
app at the end of the month but above
all finding music hasn't been this fun
since being in a music store
Oh